uh we are uh so excited to be here I'm
Nicole Jardine I'm the chief data
officer for the county assessor's office
soon I'll introduce Dan our director of
data science and right off the bat um
does anyone here has anyone currently
live in Chicago ever lived in the
Chicago land area oh wow okay so about
10% of of you okay we're excited to
answer questions we love to talk about
this topic um we have time at the end to
talk about anything related to Chicago
home
ownership um today Dan and I are going
to talk about something that affects
Equity housing affordability and
generational wealth for couple million
people here in Chicago and the
surrounding suburbs and that thing is
property taxes uh property tax bills
here in Illinois depend in part on the
government's assessment of how much your
property is currently worth and just to
set the stage a little bit in Chicago in
2015 the average home was assessed as if
it was worth roughly
237k and the average homeowner paid an
average of about $3,600 in property
taxes but starting in
2017 researchers at the University of
Chicago and journalists at the Chicago
Tribune propublica and the New York
Times identified a
problem and that problem was about
property taxes and specifically about
the way that assessors throughout the
country were assessing property
values their problem was identified
using something that's called a ratio
study so the Assessor's job in Illinois
is to have assessments that follow the
market every couple of years the
assessor does assess his property values
and adjust them so that they're roughly
in line with where the real estate
market has actually gone and in a ratio
study you take the properties that have
actually sold which is roughly 5% or so
of homes here in any given year and you
compare the estimated value of that
property to its actual sale
price and um this is a New York Times
graphic we've done some light
modifications um and that ratio should
be roughly one and what the New York
Times um and Chicago Tribune and others
have found is that in the past um an
average home was right around that one
Mark so that's you know about where it
should
be but what about other homes
it's really important to think about
homes on the other side of the
distribution not just the average homes
so here's an example of a modest home on
the south side of Chicago let's say in
2015 it sold for about 50k on the other
hand of that distribution we have a uh
nice home on the North Shore um that may
be sold for more like a million dollars
and the fundamental question is what's
that assessment ratio it's going to be
close to one well we're here because uh
so so what what that would mean um just
to unpack that ratio a little more um if
that 50k home actually was um assessed
at 75k that would mean a ratio of 1.5
and if that home that sold for a million
dollars um was assessed as if it was
worth 800k that would mean a ratio of
08 here's what the New York Times
actually published um there was a higher
ratio of Assessments to sale price for
the homes with lower uh sale sale values
so these homes that are on the more
affordable side of the price Spectrum
were historically according to this
reporting over assessed that can lead to
over Taxation and on the flip side these
homes that are these uh higher price
homes we also being under assessed
leading to under taxation that's the
problem the Chicago Tribune referred to
this as the tax divide that tax divide
is why we're here so again the issue
according to the Tribune as they stated
it is is Cook County failed to Value
homes accurately for years and the
result was a property tax system that
harmed the poor and helped the rich and
the problem lies with the fundamentally
flawed way that the county assessor's
office valued
property so what's the cause it could
actually be a number of interesting
causes um could be issues with the
characteristics data that the assess
office uses to estimate property values
um it could be issues with the way other
offices actually adjust um assessed
values but we're here today because we
want to talk about one of those issues
and one of those is about the modeling
so recall that the assessor's office
uses sales again 5% of sales uh in a
given year to estimate property values
for everyone in the past this was done
with regression modeling this is
actually a snippet of
code uh it was uh close Source SPSS um
OS based
models and you know we're talking 50,000
lines of manual fixed effects property
specific overrides and
more after the tax divide was published
voters elected a new assessor new County
Assessor Fritz kegi
and and frit started the data Department
um the data Department's first Chief
data officer was Rob Ross I'm the
current chief data officer um and uh Dan
and William I have been on this journey
together for about four years um and
we're here because tech people and
academics Rec that this is a data and a
modeling problem and that maybe we could
actually help solve it so our goal was
to improve the model and transparency
and right now I'm super excited to hand
it off to Dan who's going to tell us
about the
model all right hello everyone I am Dan
snow I'm the director of data science at
the assessor's office and so Nicole has
described the problem basically lower
value properties broadly were over
assessed higher value ones broadly were
under assessed I am going to talk about
what we did to fix it so the first thing
we did was we got rid of the SPSS model
that is that's gone and we replaced it
with r and if you would like to see what
that model actually looks like you can
visit this GitHub repo at the top um
that is the actual production model that
is running right now go through the read
me check it
out um we also moved from a closed
Source fully opaque model to one that is
completely open source and that includes
data to replicate it so again at that
link at the top this is the live running
model on that repo you can also find all
of the data necessary to run the full
pipeline to get the values that we
basically mailed to taxpayers with some
adjustments and we swapped out the old
OS model to a light GBM based countywide
tree based model so the old system had a
sort of regimes based OS model different
regions had different regressions now
one big model for the entire County
using light
GBM and to see what that actually looks
like this is the old code was you know
50,000 some lines of this probably more
you can see that there are no comments
whatsoever um it is basically just
constructing manual time fixed effects
and then doing a regression on those uh
all of the code looked roughly like this
it was very
unintelligible uh in 2019 the first
thing we did was replace it we replaced
it with base R because tidy models was
very nent at that time um and that code
looked a lot like this it improved the
performance of the model pretty
substantially but this is not super easy
code to read it was not especially
replicable outside of our office and so
we needed something
better so in 21 we replaced that Bas R
system with tidy models and the code
looked like this much more commenting
much simpler and we continued down that
path to now if you're looking at the
code today
looks something like this um so big
Improvement and we will talk about what
that actually gained Us in terms of
performance that's what the model sort
of looks like these are some of the
things that go into the model this is a
regression on sale price right so sale
price is the outcome the thing that we
are trying to predict and the predictors
are sort of things that you would expect
for a sale price regression they're like
the size of theice property the year it
was built and basically where it is
those are the big three uh those are
indicated in blue with the lightning
bolt and all of the stuff in green is
stuff that we have added to the
Assessor's uh system of record database
so these are spatial features and stuff
that we've imputed or data that we have
collected and added with the goal of
improving the accuracy and performance
of the model the things in red are
things that we are interested in
collecting or have been asked about but
uh for a number of reasons have not been
able to
include all right but what about tidy
models this is supposed to be a tidy
models talk so how did we actually use
tidy models well as I said uh tidy
models has fully replaced our sort of
Bas R modeling code base and that has
been a huge huge Boon for us um it has
completely abstracted away all of the
complicated ml logic that used to be in
that old code base and that is stuff
like cross
validation um you know tuning hyper
parameters all sorts of things like that
it has allowed us to move much much
quicker and with more confidence so we
can sort of focus on the feature
engineering and data collection side of
things rather than being worried about
shooting ourselves in the feet at every
step and importantly for us uh it has
also made the code much more
understandable we are a public agency
right and we want the code to be
intelligible to the greatest number of
people possible I think that tidy models
helps us accomplish that by putting it
into a standardized framework that other
people are familiar
with um and it has just unlocked sort of
more advanced features for us like
easier hyperparameter
optimization and better cleaner feature
engineering one example of that time
based cross validation so this is sort
of how we do our cross validation split
using our data it's a like an expanding
window of the training set with the last
10% held out as a validation Set uh this
is not something that would be super
easy to program outside of Tidy models
although we tried
we also made an r package um this is our
r package called light snip it is
basically a shim between light GBM and
parsnip to allow us to do all sorts of
fun things similar to Bonsai if you're
familiar with that
package we made it because we wanted to
use some of light gbm's more advanced
features um specifically we wanted to
use early stopping so if you are
training a model and after a certain
point the model is not improving in
performance light GBM can automatically
stop further training rounds and save
you a lot of
time in our case implementing early
stopping decreased our training Time by
like roughly 2/3 so this was a huge Boon
for us as a full training run with cross
validation was taking like 60 or 70
hours
all right that's what we did now let's
go back to our example properties that
Nicole showed uh these are actually real
properties in Chicago so in 2015 that
property um on the in the lowest desile
that was assessed for
53k its 2021 estimate was lower than
that it was around
34k and it sold in 22 for
33k so it had a ratio of right around
one that larger property was actually
the Home Alone house uh which is in
WKA and it sold in 2012 for around $1.56
million uh its estimate in 2018 before
the new model to be clear was around
$1.5
million but if you are familiar with
property markets at all and especially
the property market after the Great
Recession uh that does not make sense it
should probably be higher than
that so its 2022 estimate was $2.3
Million which we cannot calculate a
ratio on because we don't have a recent
sale but we think that it is much closer
to its actual market value so that's the
micro level
results on the macro level this is a map
of Chicago for those of you familiar
with the map of Chicago it probably
looks very
similar um broadly speaking uh the
change in the modeling and some other
things uh had the result of decreased
assessments and ultimately tax bills on
the south and west side of the
city will that Trend hold it is hard to
say um this map is going to change in
2024 since Chicago is reassessed every 3
years and we are preparing to do the
2024 model right
now all right other things that we have
done nearly all of the assessor data is
now online and public you can visit this
link if you want to check it out we have
a public data portal all sorts of
property characteristics tax history
spatial stuff that we've imputed tons of
things and I cannot express to you how
big of a change this is from the old
office we also publish uh
oh a bunch of Open Source are and python
packages um these are mostly things
related to assessment and property taxes
but they are very useful for academics
and journalists in the
space and we
do
oh
well okay uh and we do public reporting
on assessments uh their quality and
accuracy which are just available on the
website and so what is the point of all
this uh you know what is the lessons
takeway to me our work is proof it is a
case study of the effectiveness of
technical teams in local government I
think that if you you can get into the
right place with the right people uh at
the right time with a lot of Leverage
you can make a huge impact in local
government and I would encourage anyone
on the fence to try joining us because
data skills are very desperately needed
inside of state and local governments
cannot express to you how true that is
um and that is in all sorts of different
areas like operations policymaking
program evaluation tons of different
places and if you are really a glutton
for punishment you can join us in the
assessment industry because this problem
that we described about Chicago this is
Nationwide these are other graphs from
that same New York Times article from
other cities and you can see that their
ratio curves look equally bad so if
you're interested in learning more uh I
will take questions and Nicole and I
will stick around after the talk to chat
I also have some rare light GBM hex
stickers if anyone wants some so thank
you and I will be happy to take
questions big thank you Dan and Nicole
and we have time for questions and we
have a lot of questions oh great oh so
how much were you inspired by private
companies like silow and redin who also
do assessment where did you go to figure
out how to do
this oh that is a great question um I
mean significantly inspired they're
building very similar predictive models
they're not predicting exactly the same
thing we are predicting the universe of
all properties Zillow is sort of
predicting the universe of properties
that are going to sell and so they're
different markets not necessarily
perfectly analogous I think that our job
is actually harder person
because uh yes we just have to cover a
much wider swath of
properties yeah okay their blog is cool
though their blog is very cool and they
have a a neat model so when twitching
from the old SPSS model to the new tidy
models did you discover that certain
varibles were placed with too much or
too little important in the past or
importance in the past um no I don't
think so I think generally the things
that you would expect to be important to
property values stayed about the same in
terms of their importance it is exactly
the things I said before it is the size
of the property its relative age and
where it is those are sort of the big
determinants of property value almost
anywhere okay oh one more questions do
you use any model explan explainability
methods for example to help with
conversation with public
stakeholders uh we do although we have
not made a lot of those results public
and we are sort of working on that I'd
be happy to answer questions on that
afterwards okay thank you so
much awesome thank you
all